maryanne from Brooklyn is here today I
can't believe it you're kidding never
met her the one who sings all I need is
Howard in my life CBS she comes I
thought you were supposed to be like 500
pounds you talk
you brought me gabagool was you playing
that song at her singing my life he's my
greatest face all I need it's how its
little dick it'll do the trick all I
need is Howard in the morning he makes
me feel so Horne Oh what would I do
without have it on me and cbs-tv my life
would be very blue not to hear you far
purple jewel all I need it's Howard in
my life I love you Howard well you are a
character yes yes and what do you do are
you a housewife I'm a full-time mother
how old are your kids 17 and 8 17 and 8
what a span divorce and remarry why were
you so afraid to meet me she won't look
at you
no I think you think off it all joy home
and drop dead on the way you've always
had this unusual voice I think I had my
tonsils and adenoids taken out it's my
parents fault yeah they took out your
tonsils and adenoids and they probably
didn't even need to write and they
screwed up my beautiful voice you had a
beautiful I used to sing how old are you
when they took out your tonsils and
adenoid I see so who even knows what
your boys
had a beautiful voice my mother
remembers me singing and after the
operation this is how you sounded and we
obsess I am so honored that you would
come by today and say hello to us I I
mean really I never thought I would
because I remember once we were talking
to you on the phone and we tried to get
you down here you kept saying I know no
I don't like to fly and I said well it's
gonna take me like six months to lose
ten more pounds and bleach my teeth and
die I said oh yeah but I figured by the
time I try to pull myself together just
come as I am sure growing up yeah that
voice was it hard for you to meet your
first husband was that what it was no
and it's not hard to meet guys when
people find you very sweet I've been
just a gobby goal two seconds in my
kitchen
is that right totally inspired it's very
catchy actually it is well let me tell
you something Marianne you've impressed
everyone today with your singing and
your vivacious personality and I just
want to say I'm glad you stopped by I
like I like me yes thank you